Hey, how's it going? It's your boy-
*screeches*
back get it again with another original,
unique, hilarious
idea that no one's done before.
Pics to pics. As you can clearly tell, never done before.
Funny and original content!
Here we go!
Okay, okay, so if you for some reason don't know what this is - I don't know what the fuck-
How you ended up here without knowing about it. I mean The Verge posted about it ok, so,
everyone should know about it. And The Verge,
can you please just link to the goddamn thing because I can never find it all right?
You always hid it somewhere...
Oh there it is. Great. Basically this drawing will become this person, right?
Hilarious. So what happens then if I remove her eyes..?
I don't know what I expected was gonna happen, but it happened.
And thus, Slender Man was born. Jesus Christ.
This is slowly turning me on. I like it. How would this look..?
OH
WOW *he laughs*
How do they make the line so fucking thin? God damn this thing is terrifying!
*Laughs*
What is that thing??
Yes. I get it now. My God, she's absolutely beautiful-
Finally I can make my dream girl come true in this video game.
What if we make the mouth just a little happier? Just a tad bit a little happier?
OH MY GOD, SUGOI DESUNE!
KAWAII!
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
But what if her face was a penis? Thank you everyone. Let's try it out...
That is much better. I like how the balls somehow made it in there.... I don't know how...
Finally!
Finally, my dream girl, right here on the Pewdiepie channel!
Marzia, I am sorry, but I have found a more perfect specimen.
I like to call her Jerry, and he loves me for who I am.
Aw Jerry, don't be so angry!
What did I do? I'm sorry! I'm sorry, Jerry- Abort abort.
Could this, perhaps, make you happier, Jerry?
Oh, Jerry~
Related to the elephants, I can tell, I can tell. Yes.
I am 12, by the way, in case you're wondering. Yes I am
Thank you very much. Thank you for subscribing, and leaving a like on this video right now.
Yes, I am drawing a dick on a woman's face.
Yes, his is the pinnacle of comedy. You just found it here on this channel.
Congratulation, it's never going to be better than this.
Let's laugh at some more penises.
*Sings* Family friendly Felix~
*Laughs loudly* YES!
I mean I'm not going to lie, I've been with worse women.
I'm talking, of course, about your mama.
Your mama, everybody. Your mama jokes. *Fake laughter*
AH!
I have seen death, and he stares, but he looks so cute.
He looks so sad! What the hell is this?!
Kawaii desune~!
Oh my god.
Fucking sexy. This is sexy-
I finally, finally can create my perfect human.
*Sneezes dramatically*
Let's try and draw the most beautiful specimen of all time...
ME!
Hey, why not just draw myself from real time? How about that.
Okay, all right.
Nose- Big-ass nose... Yes...
Uh-huh... No upper lip, but a giant bottom lip. Yep, that's it...
Very pointy jaw...
Eyebrows that could face any anime character.
Wow look at that. I'm goddamn perfect. I have a feeling that this is not Gonna
This is not Gonna look pretty let's watch
What the fuck is that?
How does fuck did that happen?
No, no, no no no
What the fuck is...?
Oh noo
kill it
KILL IT
Man if all fan art of me was this good, boi. I could only dream. Okay here. We go
Now you're just being me. How do you go from this to this? Fuck you pix2pix you don't know shit?
Alright, let's draw the second second most beautiful specimen
That's her name Marsha
this is really my
Monalisa. In the future. They won't be talking about Monalisa. They'll be talking about Marsha. Oh my God. She's absolutely perfect
Okay, let's watch
.-.
OMG let's try another one, okay, alright. Let's actually maybe maybe I could have made her a little bit more prettier
Okay, well, I don't see how this one can fail at all, so
I mean I still hate it. If you know what I mean. Hell, yeah, does it mean finally I can factor my own porn hell
Yeah, yeah
Wait, wait a minute. Wait a minute wait a minute. Yeah, boy
Boi, you're looking sexy girl or the perfect *hamming the perfect whamen that I would finally a whamen
I can respect I know what you're thinking
What about your dog Pewds? Surely your dog must look at least decent in this.
And then I agree 100% because they seem to make everything fucking black in this game racist game everyone
He kind of looks cute. I kind like my fan art of edgar here. Thank you. God
This is why Darwin was wrong. You still believe in global warming well. I have solid evidence to prove against it
What the fuck look at that thing. It's beautiful
Edgar: Finally now that I'm a human you can treat me nice.
Pewds: Shut the fuck up. Get the fuck out
Well, it was bound to happen. What about Jackspedicy? Let's do the pretty version of Jack
it's a good thing that I'm such a
impeccably
perfect artist
I get commissioned requests all the fucking time all the time
People's like: "hey, I want to pay you because I love love your art"
How the fuck did I make him more pretty how's that possible?
Alright fuck it
They all just get fucking werewolves well - fuck that nose though
Why are they all werewolves? Stop. Is it the eyebrows?
For Fuck's sake stop being werewolf. It's not that hard obviously we have to draw the
Absolute most beautiful specimens of all time
Nick Crompton it's a God damn perfect human being and I want to see how he looks like as an actual human
*Yo know it's Nick Crompton and my collar stay poppin'
Yes I can rap and no I'm not-*
Let's just add one of the chins that he has
* ENGLAND IS MY CITY and if it-*
Let's add all the hair that he has to hide the fact that he's fucking huge
*Then the US would be shitty- *
Here we go Nick Crompton everyone
Oh My fucking God it looks just like him. I did it I
Finally did it holy shit. I knew I could do it if I just put my mind to it
You can do it if you just put your mind to it and say fuck it. Let's screw. It Nick Crompton. Let me fuck you
That's a freestyle song about my love for you Nick
Why haven't you returned my calls?
Emails, text messages. What are you? I thought you were gay, what about...
What about slippy? Would slippy look good?
Come on game don't... Yes, yeah
That's my boy you looking good bitch. Where did you go?
I'm sure he's fine. What about my Twitter avatar?
All right here we go.
WHAT?
no.
it can't be true
No
NO
*suffer intensifies*
Well hope you enjoy this video. Leave a like all my sister fisters out there
I'll see you tomorrow with another episode, and as always
*Silence*